DONALD TRUMP, AND A CURRENT
CANDIDATE TO RETURN AS LEADER OF
THE FREE WORLD, SO THIS IS VERY
NEWSWORTHY AND NOTEWORTHY THIS
MORNING, IS CALLING TO TERMINATE
THE CONSTITUTION.
SERIOUSLY.
THE CENTERPIECE OF AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY, IN ORDER TO OVERTURN
THE 2020 ELECTION AND BE
REINSTATED TO POWER, THE JOB, OF
COURSE, HINGES UPON UPHOLDING
THE CONSTITUTION, SOMETHING HE
SWORE ON WHEN HE BECAME
PRESIDENT AND SOMETHING HE
TOUTED THROUGHOUT HIS FOUR YEAR
TERM, LET'S REMIND YOU OF THAT.
>> WE'RE SUPPOSED TO PROTECT OUR
COUNTRY, SUPPORT OUR COUNTRY,
SUPPORT OUR CONSTITUTION AND
PROTECT OUR CONSTITUTION.
>> IN THIS GREAT CHAMBER WE
PRESERVE OUR GLORIOUS
INHERITANCE, THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE, THE CONSTITUTION,
BILL OF RIGHTS.
>> AS PRESIDENT I HAVE NO HIGHER
DUTY THAN TO DEFEND THE LAWS AND
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> IF YOU BELIEVE IN JUSTICE, IF
YOU BELIEVE IN FREEDOM, IF YOU
BELIEVE IN PIECE, THEN YOU MUST
CHERISH THE PRINCIPLES OF OUR
FOUNDING.
AND THE TEXT OF OUR
CONSTITUTION.
>> WE SUPPORT, PROTECT, AND
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> WE BELIEVE IN THE AMERICAN
CONSTITUTION.
AND WE BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF
LAW.
I STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY ON THE
HEELS OF A TREMENDOUS VICTORY
FOR OUR NATION, OUR PEOPLE, AND
OUR BELOVED CONSTITUTION.
>> BELOVED CONSTITUTION.
HOUSE GOP LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY
COULD BE THE NEXT SPEAKER,
HASN'T SAID ANYTHING ABOUT
TRUMP'S CALLS TO TERMINATE THE
CONSTITUTION, HASN'T SAID
ANYTHING YET BUT HAS SAID ON THE
FIRST DAY OF THE REPUBLICAN-LED
CONGRESS NEXT YEAR THEY'LL READ
EVERY SINGLE WORD OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
SOMETHING DON REMINDED ME OF
THIS MORNING.
JOINING ME NOW, JOHN AVLON AND
AUDIE CORNISH.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I WAS SPEECHLESS WHEN I READ IT
AND THEN WATCHING REPUBLICANS
TRY TO RESPOND TO IT ON THE
SUNDAY SHOWS AND SOME CAME OUT
IN AN IMPORTANT WAY AND SAID
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> TABLE STAKES FOR
CONSTITUTIONAL CONSERVATIVES.
THAT'S KIND OF REQUIRED TO BE
ONE.
>> YOU HAVE AN INTERESTING TAKE
THAT YOU THINK THIS IS A
RESPONSE TO HIS HUGE LOSS IN THE
11th CIRCUIT LAST WEEK.
>> IT IS BUT I'VE BEEN THINKING
MORE AND I'M GLAD YOU PLAYED THE
JANUARY 6TH CLIP BECAUSE THAT
WAS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF TRUMP
DOING WHAT HE MEANS.
THERE'S THIS WHOLE IDEA DO YOU
TAKE TRUMP LITERALLY OR
SERIOUSLY?
I THINK WE KNOW HE SAYS WHAT HE
MEANS AND WHEN HE SAYS IT, TO
BELIEVE IT.
ONE OF THE MEMOS UNEARTHED AFTER
JANUARY 6TH SAID HE HAD A PLAN
TO POTENTIALLY SEIZE VOTING
MACHINES, HAVE THE DEFENSE
SECRETARY GO AFTER VOTING
MACHINES.
SO THIS LANGUAGE AND WAY OF
SPEAKING IT GOES BEYOND
RHETORIC.
THAT'S MY TAKEAWAY AT THIS
POINT.
>> YOU HAVE AN INTERESTING
REACTION TO JANUARY 6TH.
>> I THINK BEGINNING THAT MASH
UP WITH JANUARY 6TH REMINDS YOU
THAT PEOPLE CAN INVOKE THE
CONSTITUTION WHILE THEY'RE
TRYING TO SHRED IT.
THE REASON THIS MATTERS MORE
THAN JUST A TRIP CAL TRUMP BLEEP
ON TRUTH SOCIAL ISN'T THAT HE'S
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
IT'S THE PEOPLE STILL SUPPORTING
HIM ARE BACKING THIS.
YOU CAN'T DO THE SEPARATION AND
SAY WATCH WHAT HE DOES, DON'T
LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAYS.
TAKE HIM SERIOUSLY, NOT
LITERALLY.
YOU CAN'T SAY I SUPPORT THE
POLICIES, NOT THE PERSON.
>> YOU GET A LOT OF THAT ON THE
SUNDAY SHOWS.
>> A LOT OF THAT.
IF YOU ARE BACKING DONALD TRUMP
TODAY THIS IS WHAT YOU ARE
BACKING AND YOU GIVE UP ANY
RIGHT TO CALL YOURSELF A
CONSTITUTIONAL CONSERVATIVE.
THE CANDIDATE YOU'RE BACKING HAS
THREATENED TO DESTROY IT.
>> KEVIN McCARTHY HASN'T SAID
ANYTHING AND I THINK THERE WERE
TOO FEW REPUBLICANS SAYING
THINGS, THERE WERE SOME BUT TOO
FEW.
AND KEVIN McCARTHY SAID ON THE
FIRST DAY WE WILL READ EVERY
SINGLE WORD OF THE CONSTITUTION
FROM THE FLOOR OF THE HOUSE,
SOMETHING THAT HASN'T BEEN DONE
IN YEARS.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE HE KNOWS IT
NEEDS TO BE DONE BECAUSE THE
LEADER OF THE PARTY DOESN'T
BELIEVE IN IT.
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HIGH
LEVEL REPUBLICANS, ESTABLISHMENT
REPUBLICANS AND HOW THEY
RESPOND.
IF YOU SORT THROUGH THE
CONSPIRACY OF WHO TRUMP IS
TRYING TO SIGNAL.
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY BELIEVE
IS THAT THE ELITES COLLUDE TO
UNDERMINE THE CONSTITUTION AND
SUBVERTED THE ELECTION.
IF YOU BELIEVE THIS LINE OF
THINKING WHAT HE SAYS ON TRUTH
SOCIAL IS IN YOUR WORLD VIEW,
SOMETHING IS DONE AND CORRUPT,
AND YOU SHOULD BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY, AS SEEN ON JANUARY
6TH, SEEK TO CORRECT IT.
>> LET'S SEE HOW SOME
REPUBLICANS RESPONDED ON THE
SUNDAY SHOWS.
>> OBVIOUSLY I DON'T SUPPORT
THAT.
THE CONSTITUTION IS SET FOR A
REASON TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
EVERY AMERICAN.
AND SO, I CERTAINLY DON'T
ENDORSE THAT LANGUAGE, OR THAT
SENTIMENT.
>> CERTAINLY NOT CONSISTENT WITH
THE OATH WE ALL TAKE.
VEHEMENTLY DISAGREE WITH THE
STATEMENT TRUMP HAS MADE.
>> WE HAVE TO ACCEPT FACT FROM
FANTASY AND FANTASY IS SUSPEND
THE CONSTITUTION AND GO
BACKWARDS.
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD.
>> WE HEARD IN THE TRUMP MASH UP
WE PLAYED WHERE HE FOCUSSED ON
THE TEXT OF THE CONSTITUTION.
THE CONSTITUTION IS SO IMPORTANT
TO THE TEXTUALISTE THAT TRUMP
WANTS TO SEE WIN IN THE SUPREME
COURT.
>> IT'S LIKE HE TRANSLATING THE
WORD CONSTITUTION FROM A FOREIGN
LANGUAGE.
THE OTHER REPUBLICANS THEY
CONDEMNED IT BUT GENTLY.
THE OTHER THING TO DO IS SAY
THIS IS DY GUSTING AND ONE
UNQUALIFYING FOR ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO BE PRESIDENT.
USE A GREAT PHRASE, YOU CAN SAY
THIS IS A DOING WHISTLE BUT IT'S
NOT.
THE BULL WORK HAD AN ARTICLE
SAYING DONALD TRUMP TAKES THE
CONSTITUTION TO FIFTH AVENUE AND
SHOOTS IT.
>> WHAT DID IT SAY IF HE DID
THAT ON FIFTH AVENUE?
>> NO ONE WOULD CARE.
IF YOU CONSIDER YOURSELF A SUPER
PATRIOT, YOU CANNOT SUPPORT
THIS.
AND THAT'S THE THING A LOT OF
FOLKS WILL FIND A WAY TO
RATIONALIZE IT OR TIPTOE AROUND
IT AS WE SAW CONGRESSMEN DO.
THIS ISN'T THAT.
>> WHAT DOES THIS SAY WHERE WE
ARE, LAST WEEK WE WERE HERE --
>> NO, WE'RE HERE EVERY WEEK.
SAME THING EVERY WEEK.
>> YOU MAKE MY MONDAY MORNINGS.
>> WE ALL GO WHO WILL SPEAK UP
AND THERE'S SILENCE.
>> THE REASON I WAS SAYING THAT,
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE DINNER
WITH NICK FUENTES AND PEOPLE
SAYING I DON'T KNOW --
>> THAT WAS ONLY A WEEK -- THAT
WAS ONLY A WEEK AGO.
>> RIGHT.
>> THAT AND THEN THIS.
>> NOW THIS.
>> THAT'S MY POINT.
>> REMEMBER, YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE AS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE WASHINGTON MEDIA,
WASHINGTON, THE ESTABLISHMENT.
RIGHT NOW TRUMP IS COMPLETELY
DOUBLING AND TRIPLING DOWN ON
THE HARD CORE SUPPORTERS MANY OF
WHICH SHOWED UP ON JANUARY 6TH
AND OVERRAN THE CAPITOL.
HE'S SPEAKING ABOUT HIS INTENT
THE NEXT TIME AROUND AND TRYING
TO MAINTAIN THE SAME PITCH THE
WHOLE WAY EVEN AS THE CANDIDATES
WHO HAVE FOLLOWED HIM DOWN THIS
PATH HAVE BEEN REJECTED BY THE
VOTERS OVER THE ISSUES OF THE
ECONOMY, CRIME, EVERYTHING.
PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN ON THIS AND
THEY'RE DOING.
>> LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT WHY THIS
MATTERS AND WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE IS.
IF YOU'RE AN ELECTED REPUBLICAN
AND YOU'RE TIPTOEING AROUND
BECAUSE YOU'RE AFRAID YOU LOSE A
COMMITTEE CHAIRMANSHIP.
IF YOU ARE A CONSTITUTIONAL
CONSERVATIVE, WANTS TO PUT
PRINCIPLE AHEAD OF PARTISANSHIP
THEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN JUST GOT
DISQUALIFIED.
>> THE NUMBER OF THINGS UP TO
THIS POINT THAT COULD BE
DISQUALIFYING --
>> THEN YOU'RE ENDORSING IT.
IF YOU'RE NOT CONDEMNING IT,
YOU'RE ENDORSING IT.